parents of ccsd students are now
weighing in after
months of turning their homes into
classrooms eight news now reporter kate
houston spoke to two mothers to see how
they feel about this announcement
we received hundreds of comments from
parents on social media about the
announcement
there were many contrasting viewpoints
all pointing to what they think is the
best decision for their child
yereni estrada is a single mother of
five trying to balance distance learning
and her job for months she's had to
bring her kindergartner to her
office to assist him during school if i
leave him at home then they won't be
able to help him because they all have
different times in classes
now she's behind on her workload and
can't focus as much on her older kids at
home
estrada says she needs her five-year-old
back in the classroom
that's the group that is more hard on
the parents
because those are the kids that you have
to be paying attention that you have to
constantly be sitting with them
other parents are adamant about keeping
their kids at home
katie busser is a mom of five with two
kids that would be impacted by the
decision
it just didn't seem to make much sense
other than to get people's hopes up for
something
that i don't think will come to fruition
busser is concerned about the risks of
exposing her kids and school
staff to the virus especially to those
who are immunocompromised
it's not something i would wish on my
worst enemy i certainly wouldn't list it
on a child
and i think people who don't believe
that it can
affect children i think it's wishful
thinking on their parts
due to the wide variety of family
dynamics some say it's difficult to find
a one-size-fits-all solution
kate houston 8 news now